Yo,
this video sponsored by squarespace.
Make your next move.
God Damn Baby.
This week on five milsuite jacket it
with ready player,
one by Ernest cline.
It's the year
20,
40 and Everett thing fucking sucks.
I'm talking famine,
poverty and energy.
Crisis Up das was I could go home player
to escape this whacked out world.
Everybody live in a Vr game called the
oasis.
You can do anything up in here.
Get your learn on hustle at a job by
stuff,
swank and bang,
whatever everyone up on that daily
grind.
When the Creator,
the oasis attempt bigger baller named
James Halladay,
takes that long dirt nap and drives a
video message and all the players,
brother say he hit an Easter egg,
you know asis and the first cat naps.
Three keys that are lots.
It gets all this fat stacks Monday for
the next five years.
Homeys busting ass trying to find them
keys and get on a big ass scoreboard.
These pete's called gunters and they
wild about the eighties and everything.
Holiday ain't nobody finds July.
Eighteen year old narrator.
Wait,
step up and crack the first clue.
See where they come from the hood,
so he straight up sas.
We're getting holidays,
cash money's one day way chilling.
In Latin class.
We recognize the first key might be on
this,
his school planets,
so homeboy teleport to the spot,
shakes off some traps wreck shop at a
mini game and hell yeah,
he get decade.
He tried to book it to the next box when
he was into a famous painting named
Artemis who weighed,
been hot as balls dropped.
Turns out she'd been trying to beat that
mini game for weeks,
but just can't hack it.
Wait,
give her a tip on a low and swings over
to the next clue.
Do.
Besides through another mini game like a
GE and opens up the first gate where he
got to play.
Matthew Broderick in that eighties movie
war games.
That's my I did.
Dealing with that mess.
He gets the next clue soon enough where
he got some company on that scoreboard
arguments his homeboy age and two
brothers named Dido and Shell toe on the
come up.
Some sites from a big ass corporation
called Ili start blowing up Wade's inbox
saying they want to meet these haters,
a call sixers,
and the only thing on their mind is
making bank off the oasis way decided he
wanted to meet the top dog Sorento who
offers ways,
some mad grants to stop playing for that
team.
When you say,
Nah Bro,
I'm straight,
Sorento safe.
They know where he lives and they're
gonna.
Blow it to hell.
Since Wade's real body is in his
hideout,
he just shake that.
Hey,
the off then boom is up.
These trailer go up in smoke and a bunch
of innocents get to murked skirt is
hell.
Wait,
Holla at his homeys and when the timer
what went down,
they all wigged out so when he skips
town and lays low by taking a new name
while trying to crack the next clue,
the simpsons try to isolate and he gets
his wool on with Artemis,
but probably moving a little too fairs,
so artemis got to shut them down.
Rookie move,
wait a couple of months.
Go by and ways doing what I call the
post breakup.
Hustle,
work out,
stay busy,
and by size dog,
what else do you need?
He ain't no closer to finding a second
key when out of nowhere are the it with
a little help from age way connects the
dots and books into a planet where he go
hard at a game of PAC man and wins a
quarter boy thing.
This is a little Easter egg,
so he pocketed wave slides over to
another planet.
Takes down again and get that second
key,
so a good till they get word that the
sixes ghosted Dido and real life man,
that ain't good.
Yo Sunni boosters,
the third key and rolls over to the spot
where the Easter egg going to be a whole
gang of census.
It's posted up right outside the castle
so he comes up with the plan.
I got by the police,
Wade hats until the Ioi to boost some
scandalous evidence,
mess with their shield and then blows
that joint.
He hit up arguments shadow an h,
telling them to bail because the Ili is
looking to offer them in the real world.
They all meet in the chat room and
conversation about how they're going to
take down the sixes.
They need all the hoods and all waste is
the crew up with them and this bike,
so we sent out a message to everybody
telling them when they gonna throw down
why they plot holidays.
Pottnam la rose shows up in the chat
room and say he been creeping on him.
He sent everybody some slinky planes to
Harlem to his credit when they ready to
bang out and she'll veils and a bunch of
gunters and 16 start scrapping.
The six is drop a bomb.
Cool.
Everybody dies.
Sab.
Wait a little bit that courtney got.
Turns out it wasn't extra life,
so he keeps hassling.
He wrecks another game and plays King,
author in that movie with the coconuts
after busting through some other
challenges.
He finally gets the East Egg holidays
character shows up and say,
yo,
reality can be raw as hell,
but it's the only place you can find
happiness because reality is real.
You feel me?
So rental gets thrown in the clink and
way,
going to see as bad check with his
homies.
Then Wade and the Ottomans Hook up in
the real world and finally kiss a year.
One thing that's always going on about
it's escaping from the horrible bulls in
your life.
Everybody's lives are so funny that they
all hold up inside a video game the
game.
Don't just give them a different world,
but one that let people shine and live
life on the easy.
It ain't just people getting their
marbles off by losing themselves in
another world,
but also by losing themselves in the
past.
Everybody in his book always geeked up
about their eighties and shit from PAC
man and a young matty be Nah.
Not that one to monty python,
but no run DMC,
man.
That's some bullshit.
If your head always living in the past,
how are you going to create new ideas?
Man,
he supposed to fully live.
Truth is sometimes by trying to escape
one trap,
people actually end up creating another
one.
I've come to see my rig for what it was
and elaborate contraption for receiving
my census to allow me to live in a world
that didn't exist.
Each component of my rig was a bar and
the sale where I had willingly in prison
myself in real life,
I was nothing but an anti social hermit.
I was just another sad,
lost,
lonely soul,
wasted his life on a glorified video
game.
So it's this kind of future technology
banging a busted.
Well,
on the one hand,
they're always.
His players can get all the knowledge
they want.
I'm talking free information,
free schooling and the ability to
compensate with homies all over the
world,
but on the other hand,
if you don't check yourself,
you could end up isolating yourself from
any meaningful connections.
So it's the always is a utopia or
dystopia.
Well,
it'd be real.
That ass ain't so easy.
They'll always give Paul struggling
folks access to education and jobs.
Since there ain't none on the outside,
but that also means that they are
ignoring all the mess happening around
them in the real world,
which only makes that reality rock dish.
It's like there's a utopia or dystopia.
You fill me in a real world way.
They ain't got no friends,
no benjamins and no respect,
but in the oasis.
Got a solid wrap,
a nice cash flow,
and a loyal crew.
I mean,
just check this one sec way jabbering
about how horrible is things used to be
awesome,
but now they're kind of terrifying.
Human civilization is in decline.
Some people even say is collapsing.
Then he started talking about his life
like it's all tight and shit.
Luckily I had access to the oasis,
which was like having an escape hatch
into a better reality.
It was my playground and my preschool,
a magical place where anything was
possible.
The Oasis is the setting of all my
happiest Childhood Memories,
so as escape the answer to living in a
jacked up world,
is it better to kick back and live a
decent life and a fake world are be on
the struggle.
In reality.
Maybe we should time Kaphar reality and
make it the place to be rather than just
giving up and piece them out to
somewhere else.
I'm.
It was reality.
Anyway.
I'm going wherever they got the daggers,
libraries days y'all.
Thanks for kicking it with me and if
you're looking to build a fly website to
shop your skills,
start an online business,
I just share your ideas and creations
head on over to squarespace.com/notes.
Squarespace's got easy to use,
tools for you to quickly and easily make
the website you want,
and they've got tons of award winning
fly templates to help you get started.
You don't need to know coding or
anything and that given all you well,
red ball is 10 percent off your first
order.
When you use the offer code.
Doug knows if that ain't good enough.
Squarespace's Hook y'all up with a free
14 day trial so you can see for yourself
just how easy it is.
So go to squarespace.com.
Slash notes are used.
The link in the description below to
sign up today and you'll get a free 14
day trial to test it out.
Be sure to use the offer code thug notes
to get 10 percent off your order.
Thanks to squarespace for being a homie
in sponsoring this video and we've got
lots more videos on the way.
So go to our channel page and if you
haven't already,
make sure to subscribe while you're
there.
Catch you all next time base.